all right hi everyone good afternoon or
I should rather says a very sunny good
afternoon welcome to building for
billions in Android I'm Kunal and I look
after business development for Google
Play in Southeast Asia India in
Australia and I've got with me my
colleagues uncle coat swallow a net Omar
in from the developer advocate team
together we're going to be talking to
you today about building high quality
apps that'll work effectively
not just for smartphone users today but
also for the next billion users as they
get connected for the first time in the
coming years we're seeing amazing
momentum in emerging markets all over
the world they are expected to account
for more than 80 percent of smartphone
growth globally till 2019 as more and
more users in these markets get access
to devices and get connected for the
first time they will increasingly rely
on their smartphones to shop the
transact to communicate to look for
information or to simply entertain
themselves and that means incredibly
exciting new opportunities for everybody
here in order to be relevant and
successful in these markets it's
important for us to think about the
important challenges that users face and
design the right app experience aimed at
solving these challenges let's take a
quick look at some of these challenges
before we get into details challenge
number one while we're all excited about
the growth of fast network technologies
like 3G 4G and LTE across the world the
fact is that it's expected by the end of
2020 we'll still have almost 1 billion
mobile Internet users or almost 30% of
total mobile Internet connections to be
operating on 2g that's a sizable and
large segment for you to think about and
solve for secondly we see a wide
variation in the quality and speeds of
mobile era networks all over the world
for example in markets like India
Vietnam in Argentina the average mobile
data speed is
less than 1/10 of what you see in the UK
to top it all broadband quality and
adoption is low again going back to some
of these markets Brazil India you see
less than one fifth or less than 20% of
total broadband connections in these
markets operate at speeds higher than 4
Mbps clearly these pose challenges in
terms of the overall experience that
users will have within the apps finally
data is expensive relative to income
levels in several markets making users
highly sensitive to data cost for
example if you look at the markets like
Nigeria and Brazil the average per
capita data cost is greater than 10
decks or more than 10 times of what you
see in the UK so clearly being able to
help users manage their data cost needs
to be an important priority if we have
to win in these markets in order to help
you tackle these challenges and support
your growth in these markets we've
identified a set of tools and best
practices that we believe can help this
is what we call the building for
billions framework the goal here is to
talk to you a little bit about some
guidelines in six important areas
connectivity device capability data cost
battery consumption content and commerce
the goal is to equip you with actionable
recommendations that you can implement
to make your apps perform more
effectively and efficiently in these
markets so what we're going to do over
the next few minutes we are actually
going to deep dive into all of these
areas but before we do that let's take a
look at a developer who's already
embracing some of these guidelines and
have integrated these into the overall
app experience that they are driving
with their users I'm going to talk to
you about a developer Val culture Ally
they operate an app called hello English
now hello English is a language learning
app helping millions of users in India
and outside helping learn English
as simple as that right let's take a
look at a video and see what they're
doing
my name is Deshawn Putney I'm the
founder and CEO of hello English it's an
app that helps millions of Indians learn
English in a fun and engaging way using
gamification India is a wonderfully
diverse country with 22 languages
recognized by the government but English
is the preferred business language all
large businesses prefer to use English
[Music]
iluminage supports over 15 Indian
languages 12 of which have neither font
support on Android our users face
certain typical issues quite early on
poor internet connectivity devices with
low storage capacity low processing
power we decided to focus our efforts
entirely on optimizing our app for these
issues we discovered that Google has a
bunch of tools that can really help
developers to optimize their apps for
emerging markets like India we reduce
the app size from 16 MB to 9 MB which
immediately reduced our uninstalled rate
by 15% also the majority of the features
of the app can actually work without any
internet today we have more than 13
million people who are learning English
on hello English from not just India but
around the world more than anything else
we are encouraged by the stories that we
hear from our learners and how our
efforts are transforming their lives
inspiring story what we're going to now
do is get into six of these areas and
talk about specific things that you can
start implementing to drive and boost
performance of your apps in these
markets and by the way what we're
covering here is by no means limited to
emerging markets these are good
principles to apply equally everywhere
globally let's start with connectivity
in order to optimize performance for
poor or intermittent connectivity it's
very important that your app prioritizes
bandwidth requests you know in order to
ensure that users have access to the
most most useful and relevant
information as soon as possible without
having to wait on slow networks ensuring
that text is prioritized before
rich-media
and images helps you accomplish that
let's take a look at an example in this
demo you will see that the text loads
way before the images so that the user
can actually start engaging with the app
despite being on a slow Network the
second thing that I'm going to talk
about is something which is often
overlooked by developers you should not
duplicate your data requests once you
fetch something you should be able to
store it and then resurface locally
whenever it's requested the next time
network connections and overall quality
is not static they change with changes
in location network traffic as well as
the location the local population
density and our wraps should be able to
pick that up and by the way like I said
this is a problem not just confined to
emerging markets this could happen very
easily in the underground subway in New
York or a crowded football stadium in
the UK as well using tools like the
connectivity manager and telephony
manager your apps can actually detect
change in bandwidth change in networks
and then it just bandwidth accordingly
so we highly recommend that you take
these into account as you think about
optimizing for poor networks let's talk
about images I'm sure all of us have
images or lots of images in our apps if
it just needs special attention as you
think about optimizing for connectivity
as a best practice
serve peppy images where P is the format
which has been fully supported by
Android since 4.2 and regardless of what
the name suggests where P is not just
restricted to the web where P helps you
improve load times save network
bandwidth and in very many cases often
results in smaller picture sizes
compared to formats like jpg and PNG
while maintaining the image quality so
it's a highly recommended practice your
user experience can degrade very quickly
if they are waiting for long times to
actually download images I'm sure
everybody would agree with that one way
to counter that problem is to ensure
that you use the appropriate sizes of
your images so consider consequence
either prioritizing image requests based
on network type or quality right this
helps you not only save network
bandwidth but also helps use optimize
for the memory that each image will
require on the device offline I think
creating a grid offline experience is a
wonderful way of ensuring that your
users will be able to engage with your
app content irrespective of what the
connectivity is like or whether it
doesn't exist at all ensuring that users
have a great offline experience by
making sure that you're able to cache
data store it locally and also queuing
outbound requests for whenever the
connectivity is restored your app should
not be required to actually fetch any
image more than once so image loading
libraries like Glide and Picasso
actually help you fetch the image cache
it and then plug into the placeholder
views that your app has without without
needing to download them again and again
this can all overall help you boosting
the overall user experience and overall
performance that users have within the
app in this case you will see that while
the app is offline or the user is
offline
they do still have a very meaningful
experience within the app whatever the
information and the data has already
been cached
one simple way of checking how your app
performs in the offline state is by
simply switching on the airplane mode on
your phone and checking it out that
gives you a very very good example of a
good insight into what kind of
performance what kind of functionality
is working well when the app is actually
offline so go ahead and try it out and
if it's not then do think about some of
the things that we've spoken about to
improve performance in poor networks or
offline States with that we come to the
end of the six the first section on the
6c framework as we like to call it I'd
like to now invite uncle to talk about
the rest of the building pavilions
framework thanks uncle Thank You Cal hi
everyone so canal has given us some
great context around connectivity and
I'm going to start talking about device
capability as the next billion users
come online and actually this is true
even if the current 1.4 billion Android
users there is a diversity in the type
of devices that users have some uses
like small light devices others like big
screens with high-definition Full HD or
even 4k resolutions some users like
expandable storage whilst others prefer
a really big rich camera and while this
is great for users it poses some
interesting challenges for developers so
let's look at some things that we can do
best practices developers can use to
support all of these device capabilities
and let's start off with screen sizes
the majority of devices that will be
bought by next billion users are
actually going to be low-cost devices
and of course with low-cost devices you
tend to find that their hardware
specifications tend to be a little bit
lower you want to start to look at your
layouts right and start optimizing for
small screens small screens will be
popular but actually moderate sized
screens with lower density will also be
huge
popular and those are really important
distinctions with small screens you want
to reduce the amount of UI that you have
for navigation for actions because you
want to let the content shine right when
it comes to density however low density
screens medium density screens you want
to make sure that the same content that
you're displaying is easy to consume
that the text is easy to read that the
images look sharp and particularly where
you're using graphical assets in your
icons or action icons you want to make
sure you're not using like thin edges on
those on those icons because on a lower
density screen those thin edges they'll
disappear and of course you can test
this out Android studio has been running
hard with productivity improvements and
one of the things that they focused on
is improving the emulator performance so
what you should be doing from a screen
size point of view is setting up
multiple emulator configurations and
then deploying your app to these smaller
screen sizes or lower densities and
testing how it looks on those screens
and you can make rapid changes in the
layout editor now because Android studio
has instant run so when you make a
change and deploy it on the emulator
again it's not repackaging your whole
app and just distributing it it's just
sending the changes across to your
running app so the turnaround time is
much faster so we can we can actually
make these changes rapidly of course
next is memory usage because low cost
devices will have less RAM and I just
want to clarify when we talk about
memory here we mean RAM not storage
we'll get the storage in a minute you
want to adjust your behavior by the
amount of RAM that's on the device and
there's one API that will raise lots of
warning signs and you should be using it
today and that API is is low RAM device
if that API returns true to you at
runtime you know that in your app you
need to be aggressive about keeping your
footprint down because this is a very
constrained environment that your app
will be running in the other API you can
use this get memory
and that helps you understand how much
memory budget you have in your app there
are strategies that you can use to lower
the memory usage are things like holding
on to things in memory for a little
amount of time being more aggressive
about releasing it not keeping it in
memory images also consume a lot of
memory so when you have a low RAM device
or when you have a device that you know
you've got low memory budget on just use
a lower resolution even if it's slightly
lower resolution than what the device
will be rendering up because then you'll
still be able to let that user use your
app and have a decent experience and we
all love to build apps that do
background processing right many of us
build apps that have services that's
okay but what's really bad is when you
have a service that hangs around that
starts up and sits there consuming
memory but refuses to go away right
because if every app on the system does
things like that that means there's less
free memory available for foreground
apps for the apps that your users are
actually interacting with so as
developers we should start up do our
work and then shut down and wait to be
woken up again and we can schedule those
wake ups with an API called GCM network
manager I'm going to talk about that API
in a few more slides but it's really
important to stop long-running processes
let's switch gears now in a minute
actually I want to show you a screenshot
here for comparison and this is actually
the Android studio memory monitor we've
added a number of tools in Android
studio that help you benchmark how your
app runs and so you'll see these two
graphs on the left hand side we have a
device with 512 Meg's of RAM on the
right hand side one gig of ram and you
look at the graphs and the shapes kind
of look the same it's because it's the
same app running across those two
configurations but what's important is
those figures in red you'll see on the
512 Meg Ram device we're using about
twelve and a half megabytes of RAM and
on the one gig ram we're using 36
megabytes
it's the same app it's actually
adjusting at runtime to its memory usage
that's why the shape of the
Graff looks the same those requests are
the same but we're being smart about how
much memory we're using and that's what
you should be testing again use Studios
memory monitor and the emulators or even
physical devices to see how your app
performs now let's switch to smart
storage could now give us some fantastic
advice you did not duplicate Network
request you should hold on to them you
should catch them but that doesn't mean
you should case things forever the size
of your app in storage should not grow
infinitely and that's why I recommend
you bound your caches by using things
like the disk LRU cache or least
recently used what that will do is
actually only hold on to the things that
are being used regularly and old things
that will expire them and remove them
from the cache now if you think about
the users experience when they run out
of storage low-cost devices by the way
don't have a lot of free storage to
start with but when a user runs out of
space what happens is that they get a
notification on their device the Android
system says you're at a disk space you
should go and uninstall some apps when
you tap that notification it takes you
to a list of apps right and they're
sorted by how much space they take up
now think about it the user is going to
uninstall those apps that are towards
the top of the list because installing
one or two apps they can you know move
on they get rid of the notification they
get updates they can interact with other
apps you don't want your app to be on
that list so here's a tip for you when
you're caching your data use this API
get cached err and store your cache in
that directory what that will do is that
when the system detects that it's
running out of storage it will clear out
the system cache that case before it
lets the user know right so you get a
chance to not end up on that naughty
list and actually often what will happen
is when the system does this you'll find
that the system actually frees up enough
space on the device that it doesn't need
to warn the user anyway so while you're
being a good citizen on their device to
your C you're keeping your app out of
the naughty list of system apps
now many users will find that you'll
find that they use expandable storage
because the the main device comes with
only a little amount of storage and so
what you want to do is enable your app
to be installed to the SD card and
that's just a one-line change in your
manifest you don't want to make certain
assumptions though but it's really
important that you allow this so that
the users can have more apps and last of
all if you look at the screenshot that's
just the system settings app and we're
just looking at our app in particular is
an app that I wrote and you can see
exactly how much storage you're using so
you should periodically do that for your
apps that are in development see how
much your caches are growing to on
various devices this image actually took
me a while to find it's really really
important that we are backwards
compatible for our users especially in
low-cost markets what you'll find
traditional user behaviors are is that
either they are so price sensitive to
the devices that they buy that they'll
buy a secondhand device which is older
or when they go to buy a new device
their existing device they will pass it
on to a family member or a friend and so
what we see is a longer tale of device
life cycles so it's really important
that you make your app available to all
those users you should target your
minimum SDK to be API 14 Ice Cream
Sandwich because you'll reach most of
your users there but you should always
also set your target SDK version to 23
23 is currently the latest API which is
marshmallow and in a few months it will
be Android n whatever the name tends to
be and it could be API 24 or higher but
you always want to target the latest API
because that makes sure that your app
benefits from the the platform features
that come on Android with newer releases
minimum SDK of 14 will make sure that
Android studio will warn you if you're
using those features without checking
for those API versions so having this
combination gives you this fantastic
position where you can have the latest
and greatest features on newer devices
but we be able to support your older
users nicely and of course we make this
easier with the Android support
libraries everyone should be using
Android support libraries because they
provide backward compatible components
for you to integrate into your apps and
in fact one of them which I'll talk
about later is the design support
library that makes your apps still stay
modern Google Play services is a library
that we distribute automatically to all
devices with Google Play and it brings
the best of Google's API is there and
the nice thing is you can use Google
Play services API s and know that your
users will have them so please do use
Google Play services where you can
because your users will continue to get
the benefits of those updates all right
device capability was a big one but a
very important one could I'll mention
that data can cost up to about 10% of an
individual income so it's really
important that we respect that when we
use data of our users data and the first
one that we need to think about the
first cost that our user incurs is just
installing your app right we need to
keep our apk sizes small and there was a
great talk called putting your apk on a
diet at i/o this year so if you didn't
catch it already yesterday you can catch
it on YouTube now but what I want to
share with you is that images are really
the biggest offenders can I'll mention
it earlier for for data that we were
transferring over the network right use
smaller file sizes when it comes to apk
you definitely should use WebP II but
you should also consider using SVG
scalable vector graphics because
scalable vector graphic images or SVG
images tend to be these tiny text files
but the cool thing about them is because
their vectors they render to any
resolution and so they're perfect for
your graphical assets right like your
icons in your navigation bars and so on
and it also means a single SVG is all
you need to put in your apk you don't
need to render an ldpi version and hdpi
version and xhdpi version so tiny file
to start with and supports all the
densities
you also want to keep your code small
and ProGuard is the way to do that
because ProGuard strips out any code
from your apk that you're not using
often our code bloats over time and and
ProGuard is there to help
so minify enabled equals true and shrink
resources equals true will also strip
out any resources or code you're not
using now many of us use third-party
libraries I just suggested some
libraries earlier I suggested the
Android support library that's built for
Android when you're selecting any
libraries for your own apps be very
careful that those libraries are
designed to be run on a mobile platform
that they're not these gigantic
libraries that pull in lots of code and
bloat your apk typically libraries that
work best on Android are the ones that
are purpose-built and if after all this
you're still finding that your apk is
too big and by big by the way your
target should be ten megabytes that's
what we find to be the sweet spot in
many of these next billion users markets
if you're finding you still are very far
offered multi apk is a great option
because when you enable it and you do a
build rather than ending up with a
single monolithic apk you can split your
apk by density sizes so when a user with
an L dpi device installs your app they
only get ldpi assets because that's all
they need they're not burdened by these
high resolution files and the reverse is
also true people on high resolution
devices or high density devices don't
get these low density assets that are
unused there's a little overhead for you
when you let it upload to the Play Store
you have to upload a few more apks but
it's totally worth it data use is really
really important when we're talking
about data in in transit and so what I'm
going to show you here is that same app
that we looked at earlier yo cool the
one that we built and here what I want
you to look at is the three peaks that
we start with here these are the text
requests and almost immediately you see
them becoming really small and
practically down to zero and the reason
for that is because after requesting
those those texts that we were
displaying to the user
we request images this is an example of
that prioritization that Kunal talked
about where we requested the text first
provided meaningful useful information
to the user and then started getting the
heavy work please run your apps through
the net Network memory monitor and see
what your behavior is like see what your
experience is like and ask your users
during the warm warm welcome as to
whether you what kind of usage you want
from your app do they want you to
prefetch information ahead of time you
don't have to make that decision for
them because we have a diverse range of
users it's always hard to find a one
size that fits all of them it's okay to
ask them in a nice way that that makes
sense
everybody loves their smartphones
everybody hates their smartphones when
they die because they've run out of
battery and apps are usually the
contributor to that now when we talk
about low-cost devices of course it
means that they're going to come with
smaller capacity batteries so it's
important for us to focus on optimizing
our battery use the first thing we
should do is ensure that the device is
not being kept awake unnecessarily so go
ahead and look for wakelocks in your
code and remove them all of them if you
can but certainly as many of them as you
are able to because a wakelock holding
on to a wakelock tells the device that I
can't you can't go into a low-power
state that you can't go into standby so
even though the screen is off the CPU is
fully spun up and that's bad that
destroys battery life what we should be
doing is firing up our our component
waking up when we need to doing our work
and shutting down not holding on to wake
locks not leaving these long-running
processes like I said earlier and the
way that we can do that is with this API
GCM network manager now I know it sends
GCM in there but it's actually not
specifically about Google Cloud
messaging the API is named what it is
but trust me when I say what you use it
for is to schedule tasks and it uses the
job scheduler on Android versions that
support it or falls back gracefully on
versions that don't so you have a single
API that supports all your
Android users and the great thing about
this is that it can wake up your app
with conditions that you define so not
just at this particular time but you can
say things like when the device is
charging when the device is connected to
Wi-Fi and if you think about those two
conditions there excuse me
they're very relevant to these billions
of users because you want them to be
able to consume this data when it's not
costing them a lot of money right not on
their cellular networks you want to do
it at a time when you're not chewing up
extra battery you ie when it's charging
so use GCM network manager for all your
scheduling needs if you are using a Lam
manager today that's something that you
should look at changing immediately
because GCM network manager is is magic
it's fantastic and of course when your
app does wake up don't have it do
something really tiny shut down and then
wake up repeatedly it's better to batch
our network request if we've got three
things that we need to do do them
together and then shut down because then
the device is able to stay in that
low-power state for longer batching is
important we've talked about lots and
lots of different technical details but
of course how we present our information
to our user is the thing that you must
solve right so let's look at content
touch ripples are really really really
really important I can't stress this
enough because when we think about our
devices when we touch the screen we need
immediate feedback from our apps and
touch ripples are one way that we do
that feedback we provide it and often I
find apps where I will have like an
index of content I will hit that content
not only will it not give me any touch
feedback but it will be unresponsive
until it pulls out the details page and
that's bad if you're fetching any data
locally or over a network your app
should always stay interactive provide
some sort of visual feedback to the user
that you're busy doing something on
lower spec devices this
even more important because it takes
them longer to do all of this on a lower
connectivity it's really important
because it takes longer for them to
fetch that data the Android devices
render the screen at 60 frames per
second and you should always target that
we have tools in the system setting that
allow you to see how often you're able
to update your screen so have a look at
the overdraw settings in developer
options and see how your app is
performing there and finally when we
launch new apps when we launch our app
for the first time sometimes it can take
a while to setup again you want to show
your user that something's happening so
consider using what we call a launch
screen which is typically a big activity
that's a single color and a light image
what that does is it says to the user
yes I'm loading I'm telling you it's
coming and that's setting the right
expectation that it might be taking a
while but I'm here and stay responsive
material design makes it easy to build
for devices that are small as well as
big screens that are tiny 2 inch screens
screens in our cars projected screens
that are 40 inches oh this is probably
more like 100 and so please adhere to
those guidelines it also means that when
a new user uses your app they're already
familiar with how to use your app how to
navigate how to go back right they're
used to that consistency and the design
support library which I mentioned
earlier is part of the Android support
library
we provide backward compatible material
design components that look great on the
modern versions of the Android operating
system as well as on all the versions of
the operating system you get that full
backward compatibility that I talked
about earlier so the design library is
really where you want to go to get your
material design components there are
also some great community concerns right
there are some great community libraries
that you should look at as well material
design is something that's interpretable
by lots and lots of developers so we
provide some great stuff in the design
library but the developer community is
always moving ahead as well and there's
no point trying to build an app for an
audience if you don't speak to say
Languages them so consider their locale
consider which audiences you're reaching
you may need to change what language you
support how those layouts look and feel
very on various languages because
sometimes they're smaller sometimes
they're bigger you want to make sure
that the text is really easy to read so
choose an appropriate font particularly
when we talk about low density screens
if that font looks blurry at size 14 or
you've lost your user because they can't
read it we surprised we support not her
we've provided this open-source fund
that supports many languages and you'll
see some Indic languages here in the
screenshot but try and identify the
right one but remember there is a
balance in shipping your own font in
your apk or using a system font because
if you ship your own font it adds to
your apk size so just take that into
consideration so we've talked about a
lot of technical things but at the end
of the day we're all part of a business
we want to be commercially successful
and in order to do that I'd like to
introduce Neto back on stage hey thank
you well as you can see we have many
considerations when we're talking about
how to develop apps for these countries
write em and it comes monetization that
are also unique facets to consider so in
this kind of markets in the next video
user markets as Kunal and I'm already
mentioned the users are kind of
sensitive to price more so than the
other countries right and therefore it's
important for you to keep it in mind and
localizing prices to these markets so
for example let's take a look at ways to
monetize in such diverse environments
the classic methods you can use to
monetize your app could be advertisement
so please use AdMob for example we have
in-depth purchase to sell virtual goods
or implement a freemium model if you
want to that also can use subscriptions
to offer a recurring billing
for app or your service and of course we
can charge for our app as a paid app
okay but in order to give you more
flexibility to set prices if announced
the event also the new pricing levels in
eighteen market yes eighteen countries
but you can price her app or your in-app
item well below one dollar so for
example in Brazil you can price as low
as one hell it's the currency in Brazil
and in India ten rupees and as you can
see here in this screenshot we have many
developers that are wearing bracelet
this sub dollar feature and would be
great if you can think about how to
localize our price to this market here's
an example it's a successful it's a
famous paid game Kingdom rush they saw
tremendous success after adopting the
local price feature the canal King they
are reaching two hundred percent more
revenue even with a lower price and how
does this possible our price yes because
now they're more relevant they can reach
many more users with this local price
okay so yeah today it covered the
challenge that developers face when
building apps for billions of Android
users and to address this challenge
we've introduced the building for
buildings framework using this framework
will result in a great user experience
for the both 1.5 billion Android users
and the next video as they come online
okay and also and also to check these
these links for more details about the
building for buildings framework have
both Android and web framework
information and also we've published a
playbook that captures the best practice
for building for videos on Android and
web and you can get one now on Google
Play and also you can get one copy of
your book right on your way out okay
thank you for being here bye
[Applause]
[Music]